it's going to be right hander jose
barrios big trade deadline acquisition
for them these are his numbers with the
blue jays four and two era 3.63 44
and two thirds innings going to feature
a fastball he uses both the four seamer
and the two seamer almost the same
amount of time curve ball with good
sweeping action and a change up
as he hits one it's a three-man infield
against lau four-man outfield but the
ball finds marcus simeon meadows
accounting for the only run of the night
for the raise last night the home run of
the ninth inning
and boy did he just jam meadows here
comes simeon in the short flip to get
him two down and nelson cruz the 40 year
old slugger now as the tampa bay ray
strolls in pitch there's a swing and a
slug out to straight away center field
dickerson drifting back shy of the track
now off to his left handles the fly ball
and jose barrios has a very fast
seven pitch one two three top of the
first it is a very deep and hot lineup
for drew rasmussen yeah that's who they
get the righty made the brewers opening
day roster for the first time then
promptly was traded in the willy adams
trade to the blue to the tampa bay rays
went down to the minor leagues george
springer leads it off right hander fires
and the first pitch lined up the middle
and a diving grab made by wendell the
shortstop an incredible diving grab
robbing a base hit from george springer
straight up the middle wendell the
multi-talented defender for the tampa
bay rays plays all over the diamond that
ball was not hit that hard but still it
took a heck of a play by joey wendell to
get there
ground ball that's going to go up the
middle
and into center field simeon is aboard
what out base runner for vladimir
guerrero jr
ground ball
this is wendell nicely done lao and over
to first the rays get the double play
jose barrios against the tampa bay ray
and the second game of three between the
blue jays and the rays
there's a shot well hit deep to right
and that baby is gone
home run off the bat of g-ban joy
and the rays break out in front g-man
joy's 10th home run of the year a no
doubter with the sound and into the
second deck i mean that's over the wall
over the entire first deck and about
halfway up into the second deck they
were trying to attack him up in the zone
and he ends up pulling that one to the
middle a 2-0 count will cause you to do
that and he's loving that bat
loving what he did with that bath
swinging a ground ball towards the
middle a diving stop made by buchet back
up to his feet the throw to first in
time to get the out what a play by beau
buchet he gets the out and he keeps the
run
from the raise
ball one strike
that's a shot hit it hard toward the
corner
that's off the bottom of the wall
hernandez will play the carom and hold
meadows to a single
he lined that one off the bottom of the
right field wall
and it came right back to hernandez
reese maguire swings and he lines the
pitch straight away center field diving
for it margot
makes the catch a little bit of a
hesitation a little bit of a stutter
step and then a dive by margot into the
turf robbing a base hit
and if it passed him much more i don't
think there'd be enough to overturn it i
don't think you touch it this early no
challenge they say
that's a liner and fair headed for the
corner hernandez will have to go in
after this one
and it's a two-base hit standing up for
g-man joy
rasmussen setting up the belt and
pitching line drive to center there is
margot moving to his left and rasmussen
pitches his way out of the jam here in
the fourth
he clenches his fists and shouts into
the heavens
excited for what he just did spider the
blue jays two one nine out so two odds
runner at first there's a first pitch
swinging randy arose arena lines at the
third caught by valera
that'll do it for the raise there have
been
some hard-hit baseballs on both sides
gladio for two including a screamer to
center his last time up runner goes from
first and flatty hits it high in the air
near the line in left out goes wendell
angling back from short he's there he
makes the catch
retiring guerrero and the blue jays boy
that was a big
big
big cut by guerrero into the seventh one
to nothing tampa bay jose barrios is
allowed to run on four hits still looks
fresh to me the 1-1 off the fist a
humpback lighter towards second simeon
reaches out and he flags it wow what a
play by marcus simeon a humpback liner
in the hole on the right side of the
diamond
simeon bolts to his left reaches out and
it sticks in the end of the web here's
manuel margot over to the 2-0 pitch
there's a swing at a line drive to
center dickerson racing to his left
underneath it makes the catch in right
center field and just like that a one
two three seventh inning of work on a
thrifty night for jose barrios dickerson
is grounded short and fly to center
swinging a line drive fading near the
line a rosa reign on the run dives and
he makes the catch the tampa bay rays
are flashing the leather tonight they
have absolutely robbed the blue jays of
extra base hits
all
through this game one nothing raise in
the eighth brandon loud the batter oh
for three tonight
flying ball deep in the air to right
field way up there hernandez to the
bullpens gone
a homer by brandon lau and it's two
nothing raised in the eighth so lao
connects off the left-hander meza
brandon's eighth home run of the year
against a lefty oh just a hanger right
there by meza and brandon loud boy he
knew it that ball was absolutely crushed
maguire the batter here comes
robertson's pitch and he struck him out
swinging with a curve ball and what a
bounce back outing for david robertson
after struggling on sunday in detroit he
comes back against the blue jays one two
three in the eighth the pitch
off the fifth humpback liner pachette
racing back into the outfield leaps into
the air and makes the catch oh [ __ ]
ranging far out into the outfield to
haul in that liner stretching with
everything he has for the second outs
and we go to the bottom of the ninth
with the rays leading two to nothing and
the call goes out to the bullpen for
andrew ketrich and the blue jays are
down to their final out here we go 3-2
and a ground ball to third
wendell's throw to first rays win it and
they shut out the toronto blue jays and
what a job by this pitching staff the
rays will throw their 11th shutout of
the year only the third time
toronto has been shut out this year
and the rays do it
on three hits for the raise two six and
oh five left
for toronto no runs three hits no errors
three left